the negotiators left the White House
after meeting with President Barack
Obama the two sides are hoping to
achieve what is so far proved impossible
Israel's chief negotiator Tzipi Livni
and her Palestinian counterpart Sahib
Erica held talks on Monday for the first
time in three years US Secretary of
State John Kerry expressed optimism at
the chances of a settlement I know the
path is difficult there is no shortage
of passionate skeptics but with capable
respected negotiators like Minister
Tzipi Livni and dr tsai Baraka with
their efforts their expertise and their
commitment I'm convinced that we can get
there the timetable is ambitious the two
sides hope for a final agreement in nine
months israel says it is principally
concerned with security we are hopeful
but we cannot be naive we cannot afford
it in our region we all eat to our
people to do everything but everything
we can for their security and for the
hope of peace for future generations for
the Palestinians the toughest hurdles to
peace our Jewish settlements on their
land and the status of East Jerusalem
Palestinians have suffered enough and no
one benefits more from the success of
this endeavor more than Palestinians I'm
delighted that all final status issues
are on the table and will be resolved
without any exceptions the negotiations
are now beginning in earnest the next
meeting is to take place in two weeks in
Israel or the Palestinian territories